what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so a lot of you guys have been
asking me to cover mat fractions run of
Ironman this is basically the run that
takes place before the one that we just
finished with like god-killer armor
different things like that this story
takes place pretty soon after the events
of Civil War and so at this point in his
character's publication history Ironman
is the director of shield now the cool
thing about this is that there was
actually a story called Ironman director
of shield it wasn't that great I didn't
really dig it that much but it was an
interesting story in and of itself but
the whole idea here is that with the
original civil war event
Ironman had basically said yes we need
superhuman Registration so on and so
forth Maria Hill was still the director
of shield at the time but because of the
fact that her actions as director were
so extreme and because of the fact that
she was so cutthroat by the time the
whole thing had come to an end
Tony Stark had actually lobbied to
replace Maria Hill as director of shield
and so he was appointed to that position
the difference here is that most
directors whether they're Nick Fury
whether it's Maria Hill are basically
kind of behind the scenes now Nick Fury
is a special case he was one of those
guys we learned that he was like the man
on the wall and so while you know the
the panel's the comics actually showed
us as the director of shield we ended up
learning later on that off panel he was
operating behind the scenes to eliminate
all these different threats around the
world it was really a cool scenario
really cool reveal for his character but
most directors are basically just behind
the scenes they are going around and
saying okay guys we need to take care of
this we need to take care of that Tony
Stark was not really the same way
because he had spent so long as a
superhero being out in the field the
swift change that came with being a
director of shield and basically being
told you have to stay in the office was
really more than he could bear so we
ended up becoming a lot more active
Danny previously was now what this does
is it actually picks up in Tanzania and
what we end up having is just this
territory where some guys run in looking
almost like Iron Man and literally
detonate killing everybody in the
vicinity now this is a huge deal and the
reason for this is because when it comes
to the Iron Man tech when it comes to 20
start developing repulsors and different
things like that they have a very unique
energy signature now this is done for a
couple of reasons the first is for Tony
Stark to basically say this energy
signature is largely my own at the same
time it's also a warning sign it's
basically
alarm bells if a piece of repulsors heck
is used in a webinar
done by Tony Stark it immediately tells
him that somebody's figured out how to
crack his armor or at the very least
duplicate some of his energy and so in
this instance where he's still director
shield he's really kind of hands-off and
they're told hey look you got to stay
away from all this what this means is
that for the most part he begins going
on this chase for whoever it is that was
able to basically duplicate his tech and
so what we end up doing is we pick up
with a guy by the name of Ezekiel Stane
now Ezekiel Stane is a really really
cool villain I really like him as a bad
guy he's pretty amazing Ezekiel Stane is
the son of Obadiah Stane and contrary to
what you may have seen in the first Iron
Man movie Obadiah Stane was not a friend
of the stark family not at all he is
ruthless he was cold-blooded back in the
day the idea is that the whole story
with Obadiah Stane was really really
awesome it spans some 30 issues between
like 1982 and maybe like 1987 or
something along those lines it was
basically written by a guy named Dennis
O'Neil and the idea was that it was
Marvel coming along and literally
stripping Tony Stark of everything like
he lost his whole company the whole nine
yards and it was because Ovid is stain
had basically stepped in looked around
and realized that Tony Stark was
basically his biggest rival now there is
another guy named Justin Hammer and
we'll deal with him here in a little
while but the idea was that with Obadiah
Stane looking at Stark Industries he
effectively wanted to take it over he
had done this once before with Howard
Stark and it didn't work and so what he
ended up doing was basically using Tony
in a multitude of ways in the sense that
Tony Stark
at the time was a severe alcoholic and
so what he ends up doing is basically
losing everything because he doesn't
have the wherewithal to realize what's
happening now of course with him losing
basically everything Obadiah Stane
forcefully taking over Stark Industries
renaming it to stain industries Tony
Stark gave his Iron Man suit to James
Rhodes James Rhodes became the new Iron
Man and Tony Stark took off now in truth
this was Marvel looking for a way to
sort of reshuffle the landscape remember
DC was rapidly approaching crisis on
Infinite Earths it was a lot of
marketing going on so on and so forth
Marvel tried to answer in the mid-1980s
and so in this instance Tony Stark was
basically removed as Iron Man and James
Rhodes took his place but the idea is
that Tony Stark eventually comes back
he's successfully able to take his cut
as company back he creates a Centurion
suit which is really really cool and
then ultimately it creates just like
this new status quo for Iron Man where
he's not the drunk that he used to be as
taking him in a more
on civil direction of course leading
into armor Wars I think it was the first
armored Wars going all the way up to the
modern day this huge Reformation of Tony
Stark's character the overall idea is
that with Obadiah Stane basically having
killed himself with a repulsor blast to
the head
this instilled a massive amount of
hatred for Ezekiel Stane himself now we
will get an actual origin but what
Ezekiel Stane has done is he's actually
put his mind to task and what he came to
the conclusion of is that the human body
generates a ton of energy and so what he
had gone around and done is actually
modify his own body's molecular
structure in the sense that he found a
more streamlined way to utilize his own
body's energy what he's basically done
is turned himself into a living Iron Man
suit and it's super cool because he
literally goes into a board of guys who
have basically hired him for the purpose
of going through and essentially taking
out you know these small territories and
then kills them all now there is a basis
behind this and we'll find out what that
is here in a minute but the problem is
that again with this explosion showing
signs of repulsor tech of stark tech
this immediately hits home to Iron Man
because again it goes back to armor Wars
now for those of you guys who never read
the original armor war story that dealt
with the idea that the plans for Tony
Stark's Iron Man armor was stolen and
then handed over to a guy named Justin
Hammer in response Justin Hammer just
started like selling all these different
armor plans to anybody who could buy
them basically the highest bidder and
what it did is it basically turned into
a story where Ironman had to run around
and fight his own suits and take them
back it was really really cool but the
idea here is that this is a hitting back
home because it's basically someone
who's found a way to duplicate Tony
Stark's tech and this is terrifying
because remember if Tony Stark were to
go into like a city let's say you went
to downtown New York he walked out of
his suit he drove 500 miles west and
then detonated the armor it would
eradicate the entirety of New York City
it'd be a massive explosion because
they're literally walking around in
giant bombs I mean he's flying a massive
bomb what this ends up doing is
basically has Tony Stark trying to find
out who it is is launching these attacks
now the first group that comes to mind
in their massive investigation because
remember shields just grasping at straws
at this point any group that may have
had anything to do with any kind of
massive attack is being targeted by
shield they end up coming across a group
called advanced to genocide mechanics
this is basically like advanced idea
mechanics except
they essentially just engage in you know
different conflicts and you know massive
loss of life all they do is just engage
in massive calamities they are a group
for hire and they're actually headed by
a guy named Moe dog now in truth we
don't really know much about mo dog of
course he bears a striking resemblance
to MODOK now the big difference here is
that MODOK was a guy named George
Tarleton and the whole goal was at
advanced idea mechanics was creating
their own cosmic cube and so what they
ended up doing was they grabbed a George
Tarleton and they literally modified him
to just improve his own thinking
capabilities that's why his name
literally stands for mental organism
designed only for computing that was the
original purpose behind MODOK the
problem was he ended up just becoming
like a bad guy turned against aim
started killing them all and then
modified his own you know initials to
stand for mental organism designed only
for killing but the idea here is that mo
dog again is not American so we don't
know if he is a version of MODOK that
was designed by like a different country
and honestly it doesn't matter the
reason for this is because of the fact
that they're immediately attacked by
Tony Stark
MODOK has taken in the space and left
there so that's really it he lasts a
whole whopping five pages in the entire
run so he's pretty limited in terms of
his role but what this also does is it
switches over to the Phillipines and it
actually picks up with a group called
the triumph division I think is what
they're called now the triumph division
again is just another instance of
different groups that exist across the
world in Marvel Comics in this instance
you know red feathers st. George mighty
mothers so on and so forth they're
basically just Filipino superheroes that
helped to save the world a problem with
this is that what Tony Stark does is
again he gives us this inner monologue
is he basically starts talking about how
whenever there is a scenario where
superheroes manage to save the world or
save some part of the country and they
gather in a singular location there's
always going to be something bad that
happens now this is kind of weird and
it's kind of interesting because one of
the best parts of this story is the
monologue of Tony Stark he's been a
superhero long enough to know initially
it starts off as this itch that you
can't scratch some sort of unsettling
feeling you know you just kind of look
around you're like man something's gonna
pop off if it doesn't well then the
day's better because of it but if it
does then it affirms the belief that you
had and that's exactly what takes place
here one of these monks in the
Philippines that's celebrating the
triumph division basically just
activates again with another
these pieces of repulsor tech and
literally obliterates everything that's
there and so this is when we start to
get an explanation on what's going on
picking up with Ezekiel Stane he
basically meets with a guy who's a head
of some religious group based out of the
Middle East it was basically intending
to launch attacks Ezekiel Stane
is basically a gunrunner he's a guy that
goes to people and says hey look I have
the tools you need in order to succeed I
can basically have your guys outfitted
with repulsor tech they're basically the
different people that you saw with the
extremist tech an Iron Man 3 the overall
goal here is that this falls into the
notion that what Ezekiel Stane is doing
is basically running this sort of
guerrilla warfare tactic none of the
sense that he's engaging in war himself
but in the sense that it is a surgical
modification to the bodies of existing
people that gives them the ability to
become bombs they in turn do whatever it
is that they're gonna do sometimes they
do it for their own reasons sometimes
they do it for a bigger reason at the
same time Ezekiel Stane and his crew
never stay in one place for more than 96
hours and what it does is it makes them
impossible to find whatever Tony Stark
goes to these locations where one of
these massive explosions happen all he
ends up doing is coming across the
remnants of whatever was there before
and then the idea the repulsor tech was
there but none of it leads back to
Ezekiel Stane again we basically get
this explanation of fall outs of events
like this and it actually gives Tony
Stark time to essentially reflect on his
actions as a member of the superhero
community during the events of civil war
and the reason why I say that is because
during the Civil War story what we ended
up finding out is that somewhere along
the line Tony Stark had taken a thread
of Thor's hair in case Thor ever died
and needed to be duplicated in turn this
thread was used to create a cybernetic
version of Thor that was called Ragnarok
and what ended up happening is during
the main civil war story this cybernetic
version had basically gone awry and it
just started killing people it really
only killed you know one one character
but the idea was that people thought it
was legitimately Thor it wasn't until he
had gone awry that people realized
that's not the case when the real Thor
came back after the events of Ragnarok
Thor learned that Iron Man had
duplicated him he'd basically cloned him
and what this did was it hid it led to
one of the greatest mass weapons in
comics oh my god you know and it was a
coolest thing like he just beat the
absolute life out of it but what this
did is it created tension between the
two because Odin son does
not like Ironman now of course the read
my Odin son is here is just because you
know he was friends with one of the
members or at least respected one of the
members of the triumph division but Thor
Odinson does not like Ironman right now
they are by no means friends and so what
this does is it picks up the following
day with this massive you know stark
division Expo that's being held now what
is up happening here is again Ezekiel
Stane makes his presence known to Iron
Man but Iron Man doesn't know who he is
he doesn't recognize who he is and so
what this does is it leads to Ezekiel
Stane just kind of saying well you know
it's no huge deal some guys come running
in they explode using the repulsor tech
and everything comes crashing down now
this is not the biggest issue for Tony
Stark himself because remember he still
has the extremest tech which means did
that suit basically is inside of his
bones in the hollow parts of his bones
it's controlled by his own mind and so
as soon as he gets the feeling that
something Bad's about to happen that
suits right on his body
it immediately encases him and then the
metal portion of the suit jumps on as
well and so before the fire and the
brimstone and all the death and
destruction can actually hit him he's
protected by his Iron Man suit the same
cannot be said for anybody else in the
building and so while everybody else is
killed with the exception of Ezekiel
Stane Pepper Potts also survives and the
reason why this matters is because this
is again a way to kind of reshuffle this
board a little bit and provide a bit of
storytelling that we hadn't really seen
before in this instance Pepper Potts is
basically in the exact same boat that
Tony Stark was in the reason why is
because of the fact that with Pepper
Potts
you know receiving all these all these
injuries and all this damage she's
basically got shrapnel in her chest much
like Tony Stark did with the retelling
of his origin as being you know
basically assaulted and you know forced
to carry out his mission in the Middle
East and so what ends up happening is
Tony Stark
takes the exact same approach that was
originally given to him it's a little
round piece of you know magnetic metal
that's put in the chest of Pepper Potts
that holds the shrapnel in place so it
allows her body to physically heal and
then once the healing process is done
the surgical I guess that the pieces of
shrapnel can be removed now the reason
why this waiting game is being done is
because if they were to go into her body
right now and immediately start
conducting surgery she would probably
die she'd go into shock she'd probably
bleed out there's too much trauma going
on there and so because of that is
basically a waiting game
Wilda Stratton will move too close to
her heart to the point that it'll kill
her or is a way to keep the shrapnel at
bay so she'll survive and so again this
jumps into Tony Stark continuing to go
back continuing to try to find out
what's going on traveling back to Taiwan
you know going into China looking at all
this different territories so on and so
forth but in the background
Ezekiel Stane is still trying to figure
out a way to basically keep his body
from reacting to the intense heat and
the reason for that is because while he
is a living piece of Iron Man tech while
he is a living piece of armor his skin
is just as soft as anybody else's skin
and it's just as easily destroyed as
anybody else's skin now it's a massive
amount of heat that he's put that he's
putting off and so there is some measure
of resistance just by virtue of the
modifications he's made to his body but
in truth he's still suffering intense
burns second degree third-degree burns
beyond third-degree burns and so because
of that the goal is to basically create
a soup that will allow him to discharge
all this energy to quote-unquote
detonate while at the same time making
sure that his body is literally not
flayed and so what is up happening is he
develops his own Iron Man suit of sorts
you know it basically serves the same
purpose as the Iron Man armor the
difference is that it plays out in a in
a separate way and so what this does is
it lays the groundwork for the son of
Obadiah Stane for Ezekiel Stane to go
forward waging his one-man war against
Tony Stark himself all the while this
story leading into like Secret Invasion
when Tony Stark gets posted as director
of shield and different things like that
but again it's an amazing piece of
storytelling it's one of my favorite
runs in the iron man's story so far but
if you guys are new here to comment
explain and make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]